reveals chilling transphobic attack
outside La Hotel
quote I'm going to effing gay bashu and
then homophobic slur and then the guy
apparently uh in the most prominent gay
neighborhood probably in the country of
which is West Hollywood in Los Angeles
well maybe it's maybe San Francisco got
more problems yeah
but but La West Hollywood is one of the
most prominent gay neighborhoods in the
country this is where Elliot page was
and then after this person said this
followed Elliot page into a store called
Pink Dot and then said this is why I
need a gun it's amazing I can't believe
it this story coming out on the same day
that Elliot page has released their new
book
so uh nobody believes the story I mean
come on a guy was walking around Los
Angeles in in literally The Boys Town of
Los Angeles and was shocked and outraged
to see someone who he assumed was gay
specifically said gay bash and then this
is why I need a gun like it it that's
fan fiction it's bad fan fiction for
liberals guns are bad see that's why
they want guns
who who is that I don't know who that is
Elliot page yeah formerly Ellen Page
have you ever seen Juno
yeah that that was uh the girl from Juno
yeah yeah yeah and she transitioned to
oh that's so Elliott about yep and then
there's a there's a big question about
whether or not Elliot page has fake
implants for the
beef a lot of a lot of people are saying
like if you look at Ellie Page's arms
when you when you work out your your
core for abs there's a uh whenever you
work on a muscle there's like a 30
transference to the surrounding muscles
because all muscles are working it's not
just like when you're like working out
your arms you're actually using a bunch
of other muscles too so you would have
muscle development in other areas so a
lot of people are like Elliot page got
implants to look like a dude with abs or
whatever I just think this person's a
liar well this story I think I think
they they're suffering from severe
depression I think that was publicly
known and I think that results in
Desperate cries for attention like the
most ridiculous story you've ever heard
I'm sorry it's I don't know what's more
ridiculous jussie Smollett or this to be
fair it is possible this happened the
justiceable that thing is kind of like
yo get out of here that's even worse
yeah Chicago 2 A.M Sub-Zero weather two
guys carrying bleach and a string from a
hardware store this is maybe there was a
crazy homeless guy muttering and
sputtering and rambling and then SAR you
know but he did not use that for now
actually he did not say I am going to
gay bash you like that's not that's not
how people talk that's not a thing
anybody's like no if if Elliot page
claimed the guy said oh I'm going you
disgust me I'm gonna get you or
something I'd be like okay that makes
more sense this kind of reminds me what
we're just talking about how we only get
potentially half the story what led up
to this interaction was Elliot screaming
at the guy because if she's a miserable
depressed person I wouldn't put it past
well him I wouldn't put it past him to
to wail on someone verbally okay maybe
um there was a unicorn that was flying
to the sky and it pooped and the poop
landed on this gigantic Behemoth of an
angry man who then turned and saw Elliot
page picking flowers for Elliot's mother
and then went oh boy I'm so angry oh boy
because if we're just gonna make things
up I'll make up whatever I want if she's
gonna make something up I'll just make
up how it started there you go there's
the story what do you think Pearl well I
have a question I I don't know if I can
say this or not oh write it on a piece
of paper
for those that are wondering what we're
talking about basically what we tell
people is I don't know if you can but
it's true I don't know if you can say
that but it's yeah I'm pretty sure you
can say it you you're not so on YouTube
you do not insult someone based on their
immutable characteristics okay outside
of that you're fine what about
questioning their mental stability is
that
uh I'm pretty sure that uh Elliot Pages
publicly expressed they have mental
illness oh okay so why are we taking
like the words seriously of someone
that's mentally ill like why are they
getting articles and stuff I think I
think Ellie page has specifically talked
about severe depression and anxiety and
disorders and things like that I could
be wrong it could be wrong but uh but I
was more I was more interesting because
of the other you know stuff but it's not
it's not about being mentally ill it's
about selling a book right like this
story comes out the same day the book is
getting released this is not this is not
mental illness this is this is cold
calculating marketing wow
I think it's just crazy it's it's
marketing just why did Jesse Smollett do
what Jesse because he was renegotiating
his contract on Empire and he wanted to
be a hot ticket item and why now is this
story come out June 6 is the release
date for page boy the new book what a
weird marketing strategy right the the
new like fake hate crime marketing firm
out there that's telling these people
that this will help their Public Image
but it makes sense right because we live
in a victimhood culture and if you want
people to sympathize with you you have
to be a victim because that would make
That's What Makes You impressive yeah
I'm real Fed Up on the victimhood
culture it's getting under my skin
just now
no no no totally agree I just want to
know do you get that you constantly
interact with victims on the on your
show oh my God
I just think women nowadays just want to
be victim it's like everything like I've
never heard a girl come on a show
because you talk about relationships a
lot and just say you know what that
relationship was my fault yeah I've
never heard a girl say that oh there was
a story today uh I was reading in the
Daily Mail and it was a woman crying
because her fiance left her I said it
was my fault because I wouldn't listen
to why he was upset and I was too
stubborn to compromise and now he's gone
yeah and it made news headlines
if you ask a guy like he had a nice girl
he maybe cheated on her he'll kind of
admit it he'll be like you know what
yeah I was a dog I was this but it's
like girls just find the craziest ways
to make themselves the victim in every
relationship gosh that's hilarious
gosh and I used to not really understand
like why guys were complaining about
dating so much I was like why are the
guys complaining like why why are they
saying this is so bad and then I started
doing the show and I was like oh my gosh
it's worse than I thought it's like one
the girls are so flaky coming on the
show I've never been really flaked on by
guys women it's like 50 I literally have
to book it really 50 50. if they'll show
up I booked double the amount of women
because I know half will cancel are they
probably are they no are you being
hyperbolic or is it really half half I
mean I don't I haven't recruited in a
while but when I did the recruiting
myself yeah I and we book uh 10 girls
for the show we have give our recruiters
10 slots and so like the that's like the
most mics we have we expect like have to
come it's for one show you'll have ten
invites yeah ten invites
um I mean sometimes we add in guys too
so like there guys it depends on the
show but yeah that's wild so half the
time they just don't show up do you
think though is it is it something about
like your show being more controversial
that it makes them feel more frightened
to do no this was even before I was bit
like this was like I like I started at
15 I was at 15 000 Subs a year ago
well people think it was the show but it
actually wasn't the show well sort of I
would do a show right and we would talk
about like
I don't know maybe the pay Gap not being
real or like not not the way they think
right like basic like kind of red pill
truths right and I would see a girl
where like the wheels were sort of
turning where she was kind of
understanding what I was saying when I
would say like you know the reason for
the pay Gap is because we don't work as
many hours we don't do a dangerous job
like you know Etc we flake on podcasts
that kind of thing yeah yeah yeah and so
what I would do is I would invite the
girls back and I would show them like um
a red pilling like video so one of the
First videos that went viral was I read
pilled my friend for the first time and
it was like um a 45 minute video of
Jordan Peterson arguing with that
feminist on the pay Gap right and so but
these would be like these would be like
three hour conversations really in-depth
like just like where I'm like slowly
sort of like deconstructing what they
believe and you know because at one
point like I mean I thought the pickup
was real like I mean not not anytime
recently but yeah you're when you're
younger right and so that's what
initially blew it up was like it would
be like red pilling women in real time I
found it that's why I found it but the
story is real but also um Don King on
women does well too woman left by her
fiance burst into tears as she confesses
the one mistake she made and she
basically says that they would get into
fights yeah I was too good for a failure
to address the problems caused them to
escalate and ultimately neither was
willing to make sacrifices or compromise
on their stance after the relationship
ended cam realize that she should have
been less stubborn and tried to
appreciate her partner's Viewpoint and
now she's now she's alone dang and it
made news headlines yeah why I mean I
guess that's a big deal for modeling it
was like woman admits fault yeah it's a
it's a sad story it happens
um I think that uh part of what this
culture does is it creates this Warfare
between men and women and of course the
man is always the bad guy everything's
his fault and you see this repeatedly I
mean I
even from singers even from male singers
you hear so many songs that men sing
about how they messed up and they did
something wrong I can't think of a
single pop song written by a woman about
how like she wasn't good enough for the
guy she was with you get a lot of songs
like that written by male pop stars
trying to think of one yeah now and and
you see this Trope in film and
television all the time it's always the
guy begging the girl to come back to him
because he messed up holding the stereo
yeah and then it's trench coat while it
rains baby come back and yeah it's it's
never the opposite it's never the
opposite movies typically follow two
tropes one it's the guy saving the girl
or two it's the guy apologizing to the
girl
but here you forgot the third one the
one that got away for women women love
that yeah Titanic This Woman's like
90. she had a whole family with another
one I know she's evil and she's still
talking about her ex-lover she met for
like a lover or whatever her one night
stand no this is a homeless guy it was
two nights it was no but this is very
real right the Titanic is an
unbelievably Evil film but there's
something masterful about the way that
the cinematography the framing and the
music is used to make you sympathize
with someone who's a genuinely bad
person like she doesn't have a character
she doesn't go from a bad person to a
good person she goes from like a selfish
person to a person who's like a selfish
person but who's selfish in a different
way and when you look I just want to
mention one thing what she does I saw
this movie years ago so you know take
this with a grain of salt but what I
remember is she cheats on her fiance and
then has the homeless guy she's cheating
on him with draw a picture of her naked
wearing her engagement gift yeah and
then she puts it in his safe with like a
snide remark right
like that psychopath behavior that is
not what a normal person does that is
insane and people watch this they're
like wow her story is inspiring she's a
demon wasn't she like talking to her
granddaughter or something she was on
the boat and then no no no no she was
talking to treasure Hunters who were
looking for the diamond she had which
she throws up the boat she's on a boat
that cost millions of dollars hundreds
of thousands of rent and they're asking
her to tell this boring old lady story
she only tells because they think she
has a diamond and she has it and she
throws it off the ship as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible